sometimes incredible videos on tick tock
go well oh he did it and sometimes they
go horribly wrong
someone needs to call the doctor huge
thanks to audible for sponsoring this
video
[Music]
oh these these videos always freak me
out oh good catch oh good catch
sick catch
oh we had like 38 flips
backwards cats
all i'm picturing is people like that
landing on their necks and then having
like a spinal cord injury it's so scary
to me
oh here we go
dude is this where's the spotter no
spotter it's like benching without a
spotter probably worse
oh oh oh i wonder this person did that
on purpose
oh yeah they did they could do tricks
and stuff i just feel like your toe
would hurt after a while probably don't
eat pedicures often
that's so cool
and that is how you get a neck injury
oh that's funny growing up in brooklyn
you lived on those you collected nickels
until you saved up 99 cents to purchase
those and what you do is you throw them
on the floor they make a popping sound
parents hated them my grandparents hated
them
so much fun
he screamed because he probably burned
himself what is your deal what is your
deal torture this flip is wild oh no oh
no oh no oh
no oh my god if he would have got if he
would have got back on the bike i would
say he deserves an award i would go on
his patreon and sub you should go on my
patreon and sub by the way we have a
patreon community where all the money
gets donated to charity but you get
access to an exclusive discord i thought
it was a good way to plug it
wow but wow he caught the button oh he
did it he did it oh he caught the bike
and flipped it i don't know much about
this sport but that's got to be like top
five trick of all time the scouts all
over me
[Applause]
[Music]
you know it's funny that's probably not
gonna cause him any real injury outside
of just like immense pain for a short
period of time
okay i already know this is gonna end
poorly simply because this branch just
looks flimsy
oh see how could she have not predicted
that i think she was okay with that oh
man what is this
again doing it for the gram he's
benching a bed
is he did he weigh the bench for i have
so many questions the chain around his
neck is supposed to work his abs more
but my question with that is do you
really want pressure around your carotid
artery while you're exercising my answer
is probably not
yes
oh
he's going down oh
[Music]
how did he not tear his acl mcl lcl pcl
so many injuries
by far the dumbest thing i've tried in
the gym oh i didn't even realize what
was happening it took me a second now
see i would find this cool if instead of
having weights on one side and the dude
on the other side he had twins identical
twins hanging
clavicle fracture shoulder dislocation
easy on that
wow
wow wow
honestly definitely just keeping going
because of the video if there was no
video staying down these are so
dangerous like never do this not on the
road just don't
how do you let your friend do that that
was so obvious that that was gonna
happen and you know what i'm even more
upset about that he kicked a football
with his bare foot you know how easy it
is to break a toe like that think about
the toe
this man in the 70s flipped off the
swing
well yeah he's probably having some more
than that whoa
i thought he was gonna flip off the
swing negatively wow my man just picked
up his groceries and said let's go to
whole foods baby
back to the tick tocks in just a second
but first i want to thank audible for
sponsoring this video last week i
interviewed professor roy baumeister
about his book willpower rediscovering
the greatest human strength i found this
book on audible and i was so into it i
just had to have professor baumeister on
the channel to dive in deeper we
discussed tips on how to improve
willpower how to battle decision fatigue
even the debate surrounding the famous
marshmallow experiment make sure to go
watch that interview after this video
and sign up for audible today by going
to audible.com dr mike or text dr mike
to the number 500 500 remember though
doctor is spelled out and that will
begin your free 30-day trial with that
you'll have access to audible's premium
selection and audible plus catalog
giving you access to the latest
bestsellers guided meditations podcasts
and so much more the link to sign up is
down below and the end card after this
video will take you straight to my
interview with professor baumeister all
right let's get back to these tick tocks
and see what happens
oh my god this is terrible why would you
do this
i s hip dislocation is happening this is
not normal human anatomy physiology so
like the only thing that is normal in
this image to me is the dude holding the
cell phone leaning over trying to stay
out of the shot but failing to do so
everything else about this is not that
it's not normal it's extreme amazingness
and a lot of leopard print turning off
gravity you are now free to float
whoa
those are some powerful pecs and scaps
wow rhomboids everything activated
making my way downtown
oh no is there a person on the stretcher
is there someone on that gurney
no way no way no no there's no one on it
there is
or you better sprint after that person
they're in the crosswalk oh that's
malpractice
now this is fun this is like one of
those game shows
oh oh it speeds up oh oh
oh
dodge dip
duck it's like one of those bull riding
things where you're like you get on like
this cake and then two seconds later
you're flying across the room
oh no i feel like the ball is going to
come at the screen is that what's going
to happen
oh how did he just eat it
he ate it did he have some kind of eye
protection i may hit his forehead so it
hit the helmet oh
wow balls
out of the way
balls on multiple levels
whoa that was a lot higher than i
thought it was if you don't land that
fall with feet first accuracy and you
belly flop that's a dangerous fall i
don't recommend that
okay oh oh it's a transformer
it's a transformer robot why does he
have a helicopter thing that's kind of
cool though oh my god i kind of want to
do that how do i get one of those kisses
a guy with facial hair thinking it was a
good idea at the time
anaphylactic reaction i think it's beard
burn oh beard burn actually you know
what that looks like to me um staph
aureus wow that looks painful that look
must have been some aggressive kissing
oh those are ants i thought they were
seeds too oh my god i mean it's not bad
i just got some extra protein but i just
wouldn't continue because you don't know
where those ants have been
oh ganglion cysts
this is not the way you drain a ganglion
cyst the way we do it is one of two
options one stick a needle in it drain
it out or two actually remove the entire
cyst itself because that works better in
terms of having uh less chance that it
recurs doing it this way you can cause
trauma to the surrounding area including
the bone ligaments etc also good to
point out that you don't have to drain
them they're not bothering you and
they're just there it's fine yeah i
thought i was an enfp but then i took it
and they made up a new combo for me
what's the new combo it's just all of
them every letter no the hogwarts house
quiz isn't accurate i took it and they
just said i was never accepted do you
know what your love language is i think
i've taken all of these and then i
received love just through cash through
cash yeah i would i got my physical and
they did a what blood work or you quiz
and i'm anemic what blood work are you
quiz that's how i'm gonna pitch it to my
patients from now on
check out my interview with professor
roy baumeister here talks all about
willpower decision fatigue basically how
to get you motivated to take on anything
you wish to accomplish huge thanks to
audible for sponsoring this video
as always stay happy and healthy